bonjour et bienvenue un entretien sur
france 24 notre invité aujourd'hui le
colonel amara camara et les ministres
secrétaire général de la présidence de
guinée il est en duplex avec nous depuis
conakry merci d'être avec nous
merci phrase d tat merci pour les
mutations alors le sommet des chefs
d'état de la cedeao à accra s'est réuni
ce week-end il a prévu un nouveau sommet
le 3 juillet pour décider de sanctions à
l'encontre des régimes du mali du
burkina faso et de la guinée la guinée
avait déjà échappé à des sanctions fin
mars elle est à nouveau épargnée
j'imagine que vous êtes donc soulagé
on n'est hélas pas soulagé mais nous
avons effectivement a pris la décision
de la conférence d7 de lézards
accra lucquin dernier qui a reporté les
meilleurs des sanctions pour le moi de
jouer et nous avons
pris acte de cette décision et le mulet
des affaires étrangères un auteur au
mollet sand arquette et à faire d'elle
une sortie dans ce sens là et nous
inscrivons en traction
et ce qui est important de retenir
véhicule possède deux des présidents
l'afrique de l'ouest et à des voix qui
se sont levés pour aux appels à une
meilleure compréhension de la situation
sociopolitique nos pays et ceci est très
important
la guinée
comment
le la peinture dit comme le président il
a fait toujours d'un pays même la cdo à
ces titres
l'esthète la cdo est
également une des choses que nous
voulons pourra le faire à l'issue de la
transition comme le seul à céder le
demandé l'organisation d élections
libres crédibles
inclusive à laquelle
tout le monde pourra y participer donc
nous avons produire cela nous avons
besoin de tout le monde est contre le
sida ou la communauté internationale que
nous avons appris le report de décision
oui mais tout de même dans la vie avec
moins de commenter l affaire dans la
déclaration du chef de l'état ils ont
demandé je les cite la finalisation d'un
chronogramme de transition
acceptable on sait que vous avez proposé
36 mois donc trois ans on a bien compris
que ce n'était pas acceptable pour la
cedeao est ce que il y à un compromis
possible est ce que votre régime est
prêt à bouger et éventuellement à
raccourcir cette transition pour la
rendre acceptable par la cedeao
acceptable ou pas et il faut quand même
partir le délit ce n'est que de ses 36
mois
ou souviendra qu'au lendemain du 7
septembre le cnrd a lancé une
concertation
à laquelle toutes les couches de la
bulle à la guinée ont participé à
l'issue et il les organes de la
transition est également un cadre de
dialogue et de concertation a été créé
et les actions clés pouvant sortir de la
transition
ont été exposés à la classe politique à
la au syndicat en gros aux forces de la
nation ce sont ses composantes la nation
qui sont allés réfléchir à un
chronogramme de la transition carey qui
a été soumis analyser si à l'issue de
laquelle la concertation que le chef de
l'état a proposé un délai de trente neuf
mois et qui a été soumis au cnt c'est à
l'issue des travaux du cnt que ce
chronogramme a été révisée à 36 mois et
à l'issue de sept décès 36 mois du cnt
également le cndd a pris acte de la
décision de faire un chronogramme de
transit mois donc à l'internaute qui
peut le dire sans me tromper que s'est
concerté partagée par toutes les classes
de la société guinéenne et ce n'est pas
fortuitement que la date du tracé -
sortie c'est une concertation qui a
donné c'est le chronogramme que nous
comptons vivement à respecter et pour le
faire on a besoin de l'aide et de
l'accompagnement non seulement des
guinéens mais de nos partenaires armée
l'acquérir la cedao donc vous n'allez
pas bougé sur les 36 mois ces fermes et
définitifs il n'y aura aucun compromis
là-dessus c'est ce que vous dites
la question ce n'est pas de bouger de ne
pas bouger je suis plutôt en train
d'expliquer comment les principes ont
été obtenus la guinée ce n'est pas un
pays fermé au dialogue c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui caractérise notre pays mais les
36 mois ce n'est pas inclus indique
talent du cndd et de son président c'est
la consultation des classeurs la société
civile la classe politique de fourrure
de la nation qui ont donné sept
principaux mais on sait qu'une grande
partie de la classe
politiques s'opposent justement à la
façon dont les concertations sont menées
les chefs d'état de la cedeao veulent
aussi un dialogue plus inclusif il
affirme que ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement
et en guinée on peut compter si je ne me
trompe pas 23 blocs politiques quand ils
sont les groupes et un bloc politique
parmi les 23 blocs politiques il ya
dix-neuf qui se sont prononcés sur le
chronogramme de la transition et
puisqu'on parle de démocratie parce que
19 sur 23 est nettement à l'appel dans
ta tête d'un pays un jeune manifestant
est mort la semaine dernière il y avait
des manifestations contre la hausse des
prix du carburant une enquête a été
ouverte
est ce que vous promettez de faire toute
la lumière sur ce manifestant qui
semble-t-il a été tué par les forces de
l'ordre
sur la question il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
le folk la gêne à la république a fait
une sortie pour ceux qui suivent la télé
ginen effectivement des enquêtes sont en
cours la lumière sera faite sur tous y
est liée à ses problèmes et mais c'est
quand même vraiment vraiment
une action
assez raide que
nous puissions accorder à la situation
mondiale aujourd'hui du pétrole et tout
ce qui se passe à travers le monde avec
à la clé de la crise à un entraîneur
d'ici et
l'approvisionnement en carburant de nos
états c'est pas facile et la roche de ce
prix du carburant c'est partout dans le
monde et ils m'ont c'est assez
regrettable mais
n'est pas faire des manifestations liées
à une ruse de prier c'est aussi très
très souhaitable mais la d6 comme il le
disait tout à l'heure
le procureur général et la femme décédée
qui me sont en train de travailler pour
que lumière soit faite sur l'événement
justement la question des manifestations
le haut commissariat des nations unies à
vous a demandé de revenir sur
l'interdiction de manifester qui a été
décidée il y a quelques semaines vous
avez refusé ce n'est pas très
démocratique comme décision de refuser
le droit aux gens de manifester
la liberté oui est-ce que si la liberté
d'evolène nuit au bien-être il ya
vraiment le choix de faire le choix à
faire entre
l'intérêt général la nation et
la liberté de faire ce qu'on veut en
tout cas c'est que ce qui est important
de savoir en guinée ce que les
manifestations n'ont jamais été content
et comme ça se dit par certains est
n'ont jamais été sans violence et la
violence n'est pas que des violences
d'état également les manifestants et les
leaders et met souvent à la violence
c'est ce qu'il faut surtout pourra
prendre en compte car aucune volonté de
réduire des libertés a plutôt la
nécessité de partir vite et bien vers
une sortie honorable et apaisée de cette
tradition c'est ce qui justifie cette
décision
l'ancien président alpha condé et une
trentaine de responsables sont
poursuivis pour crime tortures viols
enlèvement pendant la période électorale
de 2020 cependant alpha conde a été
autorisé à quitter le pays pour la
turquie on n'a pas eu d'explication il
est à la fois poursuivi mais on le
laisse partir quelle est la logique
derrière cette décision
monsieur le procureur général qu'il faut
je suis
le président alpha condé un séminaire
aura sûrement des réponses à vous
apporter mais il n'est que nulle part
dans les textes de loi qui
est malade n'a pas besoin n'a pas droit
aux soins médicaux et c'est à ce titre
je pense que de semer du cours ont été
accordées au président alpha condé et à
l'issue des sessions médicaux comme ça a
été déjà démontré par le passé les
parties aux émirats arabes unis pour des
soins médicaux il est par la suite
revenu au pays est aujourd'hui s'y
trouve en turquie
voilà il va revenir dans le sens des
retours a déjà été donné et il est déjà
revenu dans sa ville allait venir
beaucoup s'inquiètent en plus de d des
freins au droit à manifester d'une
espèce de chasse aux sorcières justement
contre des leaders politiques alpha
condé mais aussi cellou dalein diallo
qui est à l'étranger depuis des mois et
qui visiblement convoquées bientôt
devant la justice est ce que ce n'est
pas une justice politique pour étouffer
toute l'opposition à votre régime
et a vraiment à distinguer entre le
narratif qui se construit et la réalité
telle est l'une des raisons est l'une
des choses par rapport à l'avis même de
notre pays c'est la justice que tout le
monde arrête là mais c'était
généralement c'est qu'il revenait aux
premières heures de concertation qui ont
été initiés donnez-nous une justice
forte indépendante aujourd'hui le credo
du président de la transition du cnr les
deux gouvernements ces deux données
indice this libres transparentes et
également indépendante à la guinée à ce
titre la justice en train de travailler
de façon indépendante et très livre des
questions liées à au musellement watts
la participation ou à la convocation des
telle ou telle personne à la justice ce
sont des questions qui relèvent
essentiellement de la justice et il ne
m'appartient pas de faire de
commentaires sur le sujet mais aucune
volonté de nuire ou du feu était
appliqué ce soir il est important de
retenir
le cnrd pas sa bonne foi à démontrer et
dit clairement dans l'achat de la
transition que ni le privant notamment
du cnrd ne sera candidat à aucune
élection dont vous ne pense pas que
c'est des opposants à un régime est ce
que le crb a plutôt fait depuis le début
de la transition s'est appelé tout le
monde autour de la table pour que nous
puissions ensemble réfléchir et décider
de ce qui doit être fait pour notre pays
la plus belle des manières et c'est cet
appel encore que je voudrais lancer à
tout le monde pour que tous les fils du
pays tous puissent se regrouper pour
ensemble pouvoir aller travailler
ensemble les grandes lignes les ce qui
sera fait mieux pour notre pays dans les
jours à venir dernière question aucun
camara vous avez dit que le colonel
doumbouya ne veut pas se représenter et
enfin se présenter à de futures
élections mais la question tout le monde
se pose c'est il a fait un putsch la
transition va durer au moins trois ans
est ce que finalement il ne veut pas
rester au pouvoir et repousser les
élections at vitam aeternam
il appartient à tout le monde d'accord
dès le bénéfice la confiance et du
respect de la parole de ceux-là le
colonel normandie de martiens soldats
pour le moment a dit et fait tout ce qu'
il a promis de faire la preuve de sa
bonne foi encore matérialisée dans une
cham la transition il est clair et
catégorique qui ne sera candidat à
aucune élection et lui et l'ensemble des
membres du cnrd il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
et qu'on y va le faire et il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté que le nail amara camara je
vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir répondu
aux questions de france 24 depuis
conakry
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]